before we get anywhere near the actual
topic right what do you need to
understand is it one of the most
favorite and powerful things that
mathematicians do is they take an object
right and they like to look at it from
multiple angles right good morning
okay take the same object look at it
from a different perspective
right and it's heads tails but it's the
one thing right so when you look at it
in different ways you came inside and it
unlocks different go no it it unlocks
different kinds of problems that you can
solve if you can understand things
different ways so what I want to do is
connect you back to what we were looking
at when we were talking about functions
we looked at a whole bunch of different
ideas in functions but in many ways what
we were looking at there was kind of a
warm-up for this now what does the
function do okay
the essential idea is it takes an input
you put the input well cause it's
adequate
you put me with in at what you get he's
an output right now we tended to name
the input X the dependent variable and
we tended to name the output sorry the
independent variable we tend to say the
output Y right so that's what you get
out why were used to this okay but one
of us important lost IDs that we looked
at in functions was this idea of an
inverse function do you remember the
inverse function the inverse functions a
little bit different but it's very
closely related as you can tell by the
name to this idea right an inverse
function does the same thing but
backwards right it says well instead of
thinking about the input put it it get
the output what if you could take the
output reverse-engineer it put that into
the inverse function and you should be
able to get back out what you started
with okay so that's what we did and this
idea is very simple just algebraically
all that meant once you swapped your X's
and Y's because you can see we're
swapping out it puts in applets okay
this idea of inverse functions is
exactly what I'm talking about when I
say you take an object and you just look
at it from the other side right a
function is looking at it in terms
inputs what is an inverse function is
looking at it in terms of outputs okay
if you want to put another way a
functions asking a question well what
will you get at the end what were you
getting be it what will your answer be
okay whereas an inverse function is
answering the question where did you
come from what did you start with that
led you to this spot okay so they are
asking very different questions looking
at this object from different angles
okay now the particular kind of function
of inverse function we're gonna be
paying attention to today starts with
something really simple something you
learned back in like this seven and
eight okay so excuse me this is an
exponential function in the internet
your punches are an expecting equation
you got an index there which is another
fancy lift that is the exponent which is
why it's called a whole thing and
exponential okay now this equation to
the power 5 equals 32 it tells a story
I've mentioned this to some of you
before right it tells a story of taking
some inputs and getting an output now
the question is what story does it tell
so what I want you to imagine is if you
have a box you have box and everything
you put in this box okay just pop
something in watch this looking away
because it's not a real thing pop it in
and if you wait some amount of time it
gets bigger right in fact every minute
it doubles in size as you can see I'm
gonna have some troubles in a minute
right you put things in the longer you
keep them in there the bigger they grow
does that make sense
now my growing machine has this story
attached to it right this particular
story is I'm toppling every minute I'm
doubling so this you could call I
suppose like a growth rate like how fast
are things getting bigger right I could
have had another machine that maybe
triple things every minute or quadruple
things every minute okay for this
particular equation it's double five is
how long you've kept you've kept your
object in there how long has your object
been doubling so for example I might put
my object in for five minutes okay
which mean because it doubles every
minute it's gonna double five times once
every minute does that make sense so
this index
he explained it it's time it's how long
I've kept my object in the growing box
doubling and doubling and doubling now
based on that story I wonder if you can
tell me what is the output
what is 32 in this story what
significance does that number have yeah
32 is how big one time looks like grab
my finger after five minutes this is how
big it is at the end after five minutes
in other words I suppose I could say
this is the final size this is where you
end up okay so I've got inputs over here
and he's my output right if you put
things in here in my doubling machine
depending on how high it's in there I'll
tell you how big it gets okay now before
we again before we move on to this idea
what you see how powerful this metaphor
is okay you can think about all of the
index laws in terms of this growing time
size metaphor let's think about it like
this okay example two to the power of
zero okay now you all know with your
index laws what to the power of zero is
it's one what story does this tell what
story does this tell okay again I'm
actually just for the sake of simplicity
I'm thinking about the same box every
time I've got a growth rates doubling
it's doubly how long am i putting it in
the box for I'm putting in for no amount
of time right so no time so therefore
how big what's the final size of my
object and the answer is well it's it's
the same size it was to begin with it's
one it's a hundred percent of its
original size right as a person thirty
two hundred percent okay so that's what
happens if you don't actually put your
object in the machine at all how do you
know this one right again say EE box
this is time right this is time
what would time of negative one indicate
to you
type of fire that's like I wait one
minute I like two minutes I wait three
minutes four minutes wait five minutes
and then after that time this is how big
my thing is right what's negative one
mean right negative one means good
backwards in time right like popping
your TARDIS okay and go go one minute in
the past okay and you guys know what the
answer is to this right what do negative
indices mean what's it equal to it's
it's a half isn't it you cross the line
you cross the line you change the sign
okay so here why does that make sense
because if you were a minute in the past
then back then you were half the size
you are now does that make sense because
if you go backwards in time it's not
growing anymore is it it's shrinking
make sense let's go in the other
direction
okay one more couple of good sign first
you give me the answer you can make any
X well this is two five wasn't it super
fun
okay you know what story does this tell
what story does this tell well if you're
doubling and you double for two minutes
right then you double and you double for
another three minutes right well it's
doubling for two minutes and doubling
for three minutes that's exactly the
same as doubling for five minutes like
you might as well have hit five on the
machine and just let it go rather than
doing it in two hits does that make
sense
to see what we're adding up here is time
that's why two squared times two cubed
why this multiplication turns into
addition okay does that make sense so
I've got a whole new like metaphor for
picturing what this equation is telling
me right now you're ready to meet
logarithms